bankruptcy is only for companies that
can't pay their bills right
wrong johnson and johnson despite having
billions in the bank and a perfect
credit rating put one of its units into
bankruptcy in order to protect itself
from billions of dollars in potential
litigation claims from people who say
they got sick from baby powder and it's
not alone america has a long tradition
of allowing profitable companies
to put units into bankruptcy to clear
away litigation claims the latest legal
strategy is called the texas two-step
and it works like this in step one a
company moves its corporate charter to
texas where a business friendly law
allows it to split in two with a good
company holding the healthy assets and
businesses while a bad company is
responsible for paying off legal claims
the bad company faces all the litigation
claims like the baby powder lawsuits
that johnson johnson faces for step two
the bad company files for bankruptcy
putting all current and future
litigation on hold until it can
negotiate a plan to pay everything off
the good company still has to kick in
some amount of money to help out
but it isn't in bankruptcy and its
credit rating is not ever threatened it
also benefits from the litigation freeze
potentially saving it millions of
dollars every month in legal fees jnj
did this in north carolina where two
judges have ruled for now that the
process is legitimate why is this legal
well if you've ever had to co-sign for a
car loan say for your college age
daughter then you know the answer if you
refuse to sign then your kid is on their
own if they can't pay the debt
the same principle applies in corporate
law the bad company is considered a
separate entity responsible for its own
debts courts have generally held but a
corporate parent is not responsible for
those debts
if it doesn't agree in advance the texas
two-step applies this principle to
lawsuits that could cost corporations
billions of dollars
[Music]